so we have six teams for the for the
problem too is that correct I'd like you
to find out what machines and systems if
the teams are so first of all John you
and Amy immunity Oh for real milk apple
you'll be using the backs yeah okay will
be the best I am NOT you end binil you
Emilio and understanding handled and
Andrew and you and don't go wrong I
thought you know I'm sorry okay
something you're on your engine and
you're going there working on neck backs
on the maximum we're going to get
another okay okay and Roger working with
a meal their backs evil either yeah okay
you don't ok go back to score and then
not relax with Karen rich rich ok so
that's it's all about the same Amy
you're a con for ya I'm working with
defini and then we at the moment I'm i
have third program on honest when he i
can probably try it i can probably down
to effects if that's what it doesn't
matter no it doesn't matter i think
we'll be able to use any either tip for
ya right in action ok i'm running out of
money uncle my squirting on yes Paulette
that's a fixable problem yeah okay they
say it's fixable competing right okay
but scope that's on score and okay
that's five I think who's left re for
sonic stomachs ok so that's easy to get
super me to get into ok so nobody's
working on sale okay that's so we don't
need a day to distil so now okay now you
know that the exciting new change in the
plan
namely that you have 12 hours less to to
finish your programs however there's
madobe will be quite symmetrical between
every every group namely everybody will
start out and be and we're going to give
you 50 minutes to to solve this
cryptogram and and it will all be
videotape for it for each team and and
so will be in some kind of isolation
booth just the team and the cameraman
and neither referee and the NN at the
end of 50 minutes next team comes in and
we start the same thing going and we'll
have six so we'll have six 50-minute
sessions which makes five hours of
videotape which we will then behind the
scenes boiled down so that everybody
answer as a group will be able to see
the highlights of the major aha inside
specs that were and read that developed
in each in each session and of course
the a suitable prize will be awarded to
the team that gets the cryptogram
complete first and speed is the name of
the of the game at all though of course
will also want to enjoy what I like
correct the correctness of solution yeah
and I didn't I think I did tell you that
it will be an English language text cook
the grammar that okay now and as far as
it's like I guess if we just find some
office in jax hall sufficient to hold a
camera and three team members and me
that we don't
any any other equipment I mean it's sort
of a random terminal will work for all
of your program is that correct does he
know for example of chief won't one of
the cheap oil terminals as far as
anybody knows it will work ok but not
too chief not too cheap I mean one that
one of those that that exists in
quantity in the ident ability now ok so
so in order to do this we'll have to
adhere to a time schedule and so I would
like to make sure that before before you
leave today we get we get that the time
schedule for next Monday all all nailed
down so we'd like to do it all between
three and five pm possible all right now
83 and eight what do you got more lice a
three and five Chris more two more than
what I was just taking the difference
Fibonacci numbers are all the same ok
between three and eight pm yeah ok now
the things we talked about last week
we're probability and and interaction
and I guess the mixing of the two is the
is the next thing but we need some ideas
in order to get better speed probably i
think the ideas we had last week would
be would be enough to solve the saw the
thing if in a couple hours but we need
something that will get better we'll get
good speed perhaps maybe you guys
already maybe maybe the idea so but for
already been mentioned are enough now
can I get anyone to talk about their
methods now that you know that you're in
competition with each other and then
aside I still think that that there's a
as it's possible to be friends and
with that so what do you think we'll
design so what do you think is a good
way to to proceed as far as well what
are the bomb makes them in the speed
let's put it that way what's going to
what's what's going to take time and how
can we how can we avoid it comments on
this from anyone to save it I was trying
to come up with the words of English
text mm-hmm so the hard thing will be to
just to guess like the words okay so so
for that having three people on a team
might be a little better than having two
people on the teams at right is that but
you but saw somebody just just thinking
of a word now how are we going to think
of a good work Howard yeah so how what
will be aids for thinking about for
thinking of of probable words visionary
I chose right it's but it's a not much
of a plot but what a vocabulary okay so
open up a dictionary and I would suggest
going on I think there's a better way
Jerry he had some really specialized
dictionary was not indexed just by first
letter but by the index into it all
words that have an e 0 like us like some
some of the crossword puzzle dictionary
this there's seem to be two kinds of
crossword puzzle dictionary xin in the
world the one is the kind that I that
but i think dell is somebody that that
will give you all of my better words
that have the second letter is that you
and the last letter is an e
in one of those yeah and it's possible
to take me on there there was a pocket
book like that that you know if you're
really if you really have to solve
across the puzzle this is your last
resort and this is one but unfortunately
all most of the words in there are our
seem to be words I never heard of God I
guess that's across with others to the
cryptogram we can expect that these
words aren't going to be to unusual yeah
I know they've been studies done about
the frequency of words in English
language in which ones are most college
okay frequency of like that could come
in handy looking for those words instead
of score ones okay so not for example
one of my own books in fact uses as an
example of the of a data base is the 31
most common words of English language in
buying three sorting and searching i
made some search trees based on
frequency of the of the most common
words in english language and there are
rims you know after that there are a few
others that which some long ones oh okay
common words in the problem with that
meant i think is that especially if the
vote is shot and i think common words in
English frequency of us they tend to
occur in so many places I mean those are
the words about one uses mainly when one
is starting off and there are few
constraints if I on at therefore when
you can get too many of them okay let me
ask another question before we continue
this how many people know what are in
the first the first and second message
on the thing so that's representatives
of okay how many do not know yet what it
is we got about half of
half of the of the group's okay all
right so we can't use we can't really
basically the thing on this but one of
the main things i can mention the reason
i brought this up is that you as you
prepare for next Monday you'll be able
to yummy you should try to take
something that you know how to decode
just so that but but pretend that you
don't know how to decode it and then you
can you can see if some of the of some
of the techniques that you've developed
for speed would actually have helped you
but no no if you have hindsight and in
part of your mind if you try to forget
that you have this hindsight that you
know what the answer is from the other
part you say now here's something that I
would reasonably proposed and with the
machine help me help me focus on me on a
good direction or not and also i have
another cryptogram if you need to change
track to try not to Troyer said to try
your method on my place where is it okay
later it seemed like it so it's on sale
ciphers and in top three that's the one
that I took out of withering Heights but
there's another way to get a ticket
probable words may be that some of you
might have noticed if you on the work
you've done so far anything and if you
have partial the things and then you
find out what are the possible things
which could go into it okay in other
words you're sitting there with that
you're sitting there with a partially
decoded message and
and you see some letters up there and
this this might suggest something to you
okay but now without a dictionary like
you don't care not caring severe doing
just that yeah if the computer could do
this but really maybe our our own brains
are good enough to it this kind of at
this kind of retrieval in fact even
better probably at that partial night
retrieval it seems to me that this is
something that distinguishes that human
brain from computer brains is the way we
we can more easily retrieve facts from
partial from me now somebody's grown a
mustache we still recognize his eyes you
know how computers don't seem to be able
to do that very easily compared to what
I so so that's that's the case okay now
I don't see the problem is it doesn't
computer get started it doesn't help you
get started okay so now if anyone have
an idea for how to get all of the first
hurdle once you once you've got enough
of it than you think you can fill in the
others and as a matter of getting a
critical mass of the solution going so
what's the first thing that you would
try it's all on these cookie goes
frequent words that have we call the
program property two letters had to
provide an appropriate amount the door
the more occurrences of the program
property in the word the fewer chances
that it could be matching by accident
okay that's a good point that the that
this this property that we had last time
that you said about half of the words in
English satisfy the the chance of false
graph so that a false hits is is seems
to be smaller on those because why well
for instance if you just have one match
of the program
in consecutive butters then they're only
now you can only have it for twenty six
pairs of letters there and then um if
you have it again then you have to take
the intersection of those two sets and
you keep picking intersections and it
gets keeps getting smaller okay so so in
some sense that the fact that we're
using the same part of the of the F
function of the unknown F function
instead of different parts is giving us
let's get in and as well as the fact
that what you were getting two
confirmations of it of the same part of
the F function it seems a little more
it's more reliable I I did learn
something that's that that impressed me
as I was weren't working on me on this
myself and that is I found where i was
making where i was afterwards after I
made a mistake I tried to find out I try
to say well help how had I gone wrong
and one of the things that i would put
in a in an eight-letter crib including
including a space at the end at each end
of the work so i had a six letter word
and i put spaces before and after and i
got a hit I said oh gosh eight letters
in the hit that's pretty convincing well
it turned out that only seven that one
of those spaces was really a semicolon
or carriage return or something else you
know the punctuation loss and and the
thing that occurred that I realized then
was that eight-letter it is pretty
impressive but it doesn't necessarily
isn't that much stronger than seven
letters followed by another asking is
there a space after the word within a
space afterward has a probability of
about thirty or forty percent of being
there any of working anyway somehow I
mean there's there's a spills do the
chance of that that the things that that
you evenly have a long hit Oh is there
still a chance that individual letters
of that hit might not be too reliable
but budgeting so you don't have to
believe something just because it's just
because the total event was was
improbable
it's uh it's still mostly improbable
followed by one probable or some
hydroponic under that algebra okay so
the main ideas on how to get how to get
going I like it started besides that so
that's one of them try try English words
that that have that had is property
what's a good one well in someone
mentioned any word in any just a suffix
king tee ILY nada tion that has a the
o/n the o/n is okay tion is another so
in other words suffix is not forwards is
another pregnancy words is another is
another possible win okay now okay let
me see does any of you have a program
that that would that I could tell matt
to and and try on my new cryptogram to
see what would what do we do you can do
this and I'm tribe and I can use your
yes on score yes I've been running it on
SAS a lot but there's a copy on scope
because I move gently it printed okay
well let me try that just to see if our
computer thing gets going well see if I
mean I want to try out this this machine
just about you can actually moving ok so
it's gone yeah you better log in
I you guys will be able to watch it on
that monitor up there anything so it is
oh well this is high bays okay we're not
going to go to pass where the first
piece it's okay it'll be it'll Italy
it's not going out there okay it's gone
now I'm sorry I at least I hid you from
the others sale you all right I got to
bring up over the file yeah okay I'll
bring over a file first but let's a
control C I guess see there's some kind
of them no I know how control season oh
that's here okay now there's a some kind
of a transparent mode that I don't
remember how to get so it's hope it's
good enough ok ftp say on ok now let's
see
this is no good ok so now get ok ok so
quick all right now get going ok this
cipher this cipher number three is it
was taken from near the beginning of
withering Heights a novel does anybody
know this novel by and yeah but what my
heart oh ok ok so it's by gosh what
sobrante what one of them Bronte sisters
huh and what Charlotte Emily yeah okay
focus and and I just this was just to
give us some ideas as to what you might
be faced with next Monday but wow it's
white look try to generalize from from
these experiences and why we work on
this problem i should also mention
keeping back your mind what are the key
things that make it succeed for you so
that if you were designing a better
quick command for unix what would you do
that would defeat all of the things that
works that we're doing here you know
something if you get this thing running
really well you could you know maybe you
and get the UNIX people to put it in as
a program for decrypting think they were
yeah just like the available for use
with Justin oh god it's terrible now of
course we should in cyber it first okay
now Kathy what okay we can't we can't
see you because your shoulders are I
didn't want your password to be showing
all the time okay so we can see a little
bit here that she's running something
called decrypt input is in English text
okay okay these don't these look like a
combination of Pascal English so that
you can use you can use the same program
on both is that right do we have a like
somebody has an almost procedure for
example ok so it's called cipher three
okay now what okay healthy okay all
right okay so Prince decrypted text so
far add a guest to F guess a word print
the current map onto a previous guest
print the cipher as text at a word and
begin guessing from the start again yeah
you can start again just needs to be
stopped being promoted Flynn is for the
beginning of the case all right so so
let's type something now be hmm g-guess
a word ok so it's suggesting a word for
you but that the idea ok see if we still
have our base 32 arithmetic in here you
know I really like Ramses idea to use a
letter codes instead of instead of
number so that you can as long as what
yeah the reason to another say is
because manitex simple Avery four
corners screen you see the nose and
right hand side the screen yup
concordance right um or you can just
give an absolute number yeah yeah but I
would like what I was thinking is that
that a decimal or octal or any other
number system isn't really critical as
long as we have a one-to-one
correspondence tub ok so now look at
that we have we have already found it's
at a dollar sign it's dull side in this
message well that's one of the
one of the feasible characters rear legs
have yes Scott it seems a lot me the
reading which takes to that it wouldn't
probably bounce I would be more likely
but people ok but like explain what what
happened then you typed only a G and if
it and already put in a few of these
things what so what is the what if what
do son be inconvenient sock cake school
and looks the layers which would I want
hot here the design the white itself the
program we had a discipline haha right
right so industries that had anesthesia
range suppose that would be so lately
and first one that it found was had in
that position I see and this is and it's
entirely as a consequence of putting
have in that position that's right yes
okay it's also now quit but the fact
that also showed up a dollar sign it
makes it unlikely is that dollar sign
was only a consequence of hell okay so
it might have been a nice shades or
something else are having your dad okay
and it was that one okay and this one is
it down will ya what is costly it found
us no this is a Pascal photo maybe I've
given you the wrong to run x value
funny feel it after it okay seems a lot
well yeah but this reminds me that our
news department chairman is the plural
of meal cookies publish count really
opposite on hanging out email is the
answer okay make waiting on what is this
a comma period mm-hmm well that's
reasonable text to help commons alright
so that one looks okay we got hm and Ian
here what's the word of him mate mate
night yeah this says make please and I
put spaces how does it decide which
already tried fitting image it just
defines a little bit then it funds that
tries all the words miss least the
English and possible many will be
impossible because of the invisible
characters or magical things are already
there it's scars so name is this minus
is the dinner clash mmm before we go on
does anyone have an idea how we could
already use the example that we've seen
so far to to to speed up what we've done
I mean but put you know with with it
suppose you had this program already
well how could you change it slightly to
to make maybe maybe go a little faster
also look for likely in the sched
unlikely things like dollar signs and
things like that could also be in other
words that there could be some kind of a
probability added to this saying that
it's legal button but though but not as
probable and maybe maybe some kind of a
rank ordering could be computed up
before it presents the answers yeah
change that I blacksmith has just
changed the list of words which I give
the beginning to something I thought of
doing but because I haven't really
looked program today or yesterday I
haven't done it yet because change the
sub words said it grows so it's looking
for things like ing rather then complete
what is I think yeah what's a petite but
the the fact that federal dollar sign
flashes up up was it was a pretty much
of a giveaway to us although although
there are some characters that are that
are um you know like expose it was a
number two or something like that okay
well you can use to you know how
punctuation marks they do occur
exclamation points so on they aren't in
it in your usual frequency counts that
you get when you just consider
frequencies of English words but
annoying spaces are are are also
something to take into consideration but
but the but there's some kind of
plausibility index that says well yeah
this could be this could be but but you
don't want to rule it out absolutely
impossible but still various rather
unlikely and we should talk a little
more but ok I will get it closed
upstairs another thing that might help
at least maybe not so much in the early
stages of the game but later on um is
but it puts a word in may have it
highlight the characters that appear as
a result of that particular insertion
okay not something flashing or something
that hot some way to focus attention to
the consequences of what you just did
the time do you feel if there's a way to
do that mm-hmm so so so a way to get
some visual cues okay
let's take a lot as I outside it's not
easy in some programming languages pesca
it would evolve now for data terminal I
think too there's nothing any libraries
around but I know thank goodness many
loggers let me do this easily on with
Pascal you mean has gone yeah quite I'd
invited mean anything fancy like
inversion video or anything but I'm just
like I'm pretty extra well maybe
under mat and it underscores it not
something like that yeah that would
probably make it happen how hard it is
yeah he's our me know okay assault
assault yeah there might be a way to
think about good way to highlight it by
eating a fresh towel but not maybe his
compassion yeah but you have to
character code though so it might be
possible to do that come on yeah and
it's not sure it's not clear exactly how
much some of those things a little but
at this point it's easy for us to see
because we have only one out one part
but maybe after actually if things get a
lot of good going okay so it looks like
we have a make in the middle there
that's odd free now let's try to see
what else it does you too osteo soon but
one fan and
Christine your previous stages is the
Nelson B in monitor takes strike oh yeah
that's good for not that's par for that
that's that's that's fair game to look
for Noel's at the end backslash zero you
can specify you know where does it go ok
yeah where you want to say to 55 yeah ok
ok yeah the reason is that i took this
out of the middle of a pages with
withering Heights and it doesn't it's
not the same as the other message was
was a complete page by itself yeah and a
page a page in the editing system that i
was using is filled out with melons at
the end if it's less than 256 characters
ok that would have that would have been
a good idea for the message for the
stackers that you had in class but it's
when it looks long but for women high
side we might be in the middle of a word
in fact at the end here because this has
just taken out of the out of the
beginning of the middle of a file next
thing I try to spicy's mm-hmm I really
appreciate your being a guinea pig for
us Kathy that it helped what else would
go after a comma by the way through
things inside a carriage return yeah
anything else space space carriage
return in you know in a withering
Heights know what what else in addition
quotation marks the ionic technology
last that would be good about all we
would we would expect there after state
after
is this okay it seems to been okay all
right did that give us any more letter
what's on the bottom row there it might
also be useful but it could tell you
which positions are most likely to gain
by guessing okay so so look ahead to say
what how many places in really effect is
really how many times at fiu occurred
that's all you occurred okay it might
also be knows perhaps 2pm say if how
many possibilities are there for a given
size pretty complacent in scientist for
that again is was originally really too
much well there's a balance between
between compute time and ER music
supposing that we increase the amount of
money in your account sufficiently
there's a certain balance at the other
end two of you time I like though we're
trying to get fast yeah sorry ah hi pup
this is essentially a constraint
satisfaction problem constraint
satisfaction problem yes essentially or
how you have a function f which you have
to satisfy under you have a set of
constraints and also the center the
constraint of reasonableness which
presumably I doubt we can program into
it but ok so that's something which
garage it and there are exist systems
which is the very efficiently workout
constraint satisfaction problems for you
very complicated for instance there is a
system called Alice Alice yeah yes by
Lauria and of course that doesn't I
don't know how well it would work for
this kind of constraints but which has
been shown to work very well for general
problems constraint satisfaction
problems so in theory if one was really
working on if one could even say to you
so you could you could you if Alex alice
is running and some
so you could give you two have into it's
uh it wouldn't it wouldn't be out of the
question to use of it to use someone
else's program in a creative way in this
course I guess so but constraint
satisfaction that's that's every time I
mean that's building bridges that covers
everything the work that you just put in
like you just put in your constraint and
Alice say how I said I saw you hit the
earth suggestion and presumably one
could edit something some code which
would also ask you with it as a
constraint whether thing was reasonable
mm-hmm and I am not sure what if you're
easily get to get strikes me that
somehow we should be able to do better
with a special purpose thing much better
than a fine a general purpose could give
us but but it would be interesting to be
proved wrong on that point incidentally
this as the matter of results it has
been shown that the program when you
model some specialized things like
traveling salesman problem or some of
the rudys problems as a constraint
satisfaction problem and solve it on how
this has been shown on the average will
give as good results as specialized
programs for the purpose so how else
interesting here especially if it's been
verified by somebody other than the
author of alice lee this is how you
should try to see how how she does on
this on this man constraint
might be a bit never give the cassettes
it's a bench but yeah mm-hmm okay um for
shopping sales when they're fairly good
constraints you can use them and I'm
sure it depends on from the problem the
well the that the problem three is also
going to be a special case of
constraints in some way then so we might
be able to return to the subject and
yeah okay why do we talk about a ding
dong now we have a week what space after
comment was pretty clear but what else
do you think we can do to a space after
make and before me and before the spice
basis that I'll make see if that does
any good
but somebody ever watched I was looking
for you just 20 types return nothing
happened that's called time sharing I
did you wrong address okay well well
give it 28 was where the e was so it's a
good thing that it didn't allow a space
there is that right okay this leads to
an invisible character 229 now notice
there's no point trying to do after that
because those be there it would be
really a walls because the character
yeah post-roman hmm you might be would
make it the other ones I'm probably yes
if I as possible it may kiss me
er okay okay ton of those others work
huh all right well what is there a way
for you to sort of let let you thing run
and put in the casters so loosely excuse
me one way to do it might be simply just
to go ahead and not care about making
bad guess is too much and let the
Machine keep suggesting stuff so here
said good I continue yeah one little
good unless somebody else wanted not a
people then some this gives plus sign
the face rising oh oh oh there's not
much mathematics in there Oh God
footnote
now all right this is a really clean
your head out right okay there's a QE is
that right to be yeah uh-huh kill he
doesn't go either visit to make okay so
that swings up another point his risk
isn't be followed by now QE is something
that brings up another point worth
mentioning that is such there's also
pairs of letters that we know are very
unlikely you know what individual
letters are are there ok so it's also
sick it also if someone wants to
automate some of this plausibility thing
they could also have some way I'm
looking at pairs of letters instead of
individually actually burst I think was
scientific american but um around
nineteen seventy or so there's not a
class when they took up that talk about
just that it was zero voter monkeys
first for the monkeys were anantha
monkey is one that considers the
probability of a letter occurring after
the preceding and minus 1 letters yeah
that's that's right it's it's uh i think
it was John mmm-hmm from Bell Labs who
went to Calcutta captain famous
scientist oh gosh name was John and he
he needed these experiments with with
randomly generated English text where
you you use a Markov process in industry
it says that the states of your text
depend on the previous sub K characters
that you've generated and given those
characters then you know the probability
distribution of the next character if
you get so following following it Q for
example if you had only cake as one then
it would give you very high probability
over you following it almost almost
total
I guess in English there's only a few
African tribes or something car support
like some are conned with a queue in
intersection but mostly it's going to be
having you after it and so it almost
surely will generate of you and then
after you it has a certain probability
of submission is what the next letter is
and then for different values of K you
can generate different order to detect
same has been tried for music and that
was to done in fact in harvard in the
50s of where they fit in a stiff ha i
think it was a few hundred hymns from
the methodist hymnal end of and they
tried these patterns and they found out
that when when you took k equals six it
would reproduce one of the hymns
entirely you know because there was only
six notes we would guarantee that you
the next note would be forced it would
only appear once in the daily some
people use the credit livermore to to
generate the english text and also
random pascal text and random text from
a computer man that abyss they had over
there was was the documentation for one
of their operating systems and so they
they generated random random
documentation unless many fun it was a
project that they turn in once in 163
classic and so on so so this kind of but
this kind of data by the way you can get
just by looking at some files that are
already in the computer on for example
of things from the new service or
something like that butler dictionary is
not the best way to get the this
frequencies because who doesn't include
carriage returns and punctuation marks
and spaces and the right frequency is
down the writing anyway well now what
happened now how the queue is back in
use or it's okay we can wait
and have yeah that sounds pretty good
there's a capital z RS insist that what
I would like to do candy just plunge
ahead though away and then we see the my
hypothesis is Eddie that supposed to let
me give you this whole message but but
collaborate every letter with with the
state eighty percent probability is
thirty percent probability but but still
it would be consistent with with ascii
code so you so so so if you have them so
you have a letter that has a bunch of
asterisks in it maybe even your message
with asterisks and impossible things but
still there might be some combination of
letters that just strikes you that it
has that that you do know the truth even
though even though it's been mostly
destroyed so maybe by pushed plunging
ahead finish to answer those questions
that you know mr. anythings you sleep
with a good because you if you answer
yes then you're constrained it a bit
more oh okay well what um I don't
understand you don't want to constrain
your son well if you want to see all the
possible words yeah then every time you
add would you had more constraints to
than that that you're using yeah for EM
so by suppose we don't care if they're
but that night cancel a hostel woods
like if you make yo guess yeah a chance
that the right a slight wrong yeah thank
you straight example yeah that's okay
what I was saying is that we might we
might still even though we make bad
mistakes now that might not be too bad
kid would I throw we can we always have
this be come and it will take us all the
way back to the beginning so is there a
way to set it up just sort of go go go
go
its energy excuse me I thought so
Demetri what do you think that you can
guess English words fast enough not
being a native speaker them yes I ever
agree to it because it very good now i'm
not sure if this is I if this is you
know discriminating against the people
who of course you were born in in
Tanzania anything yeah that means being
English almost since those ball things
done because I noticed when I came back
from a sabbatical in Europe I couldn't
play Scrabble any more competitively
because I kept thinking of Norwegian
words that wouldn't be allowed in the
game but it was interfering just like
your norwegian dictionary in there it
would be ah yeah we have to allow it
okay so we got some zing zing is it the
things all right i J okay we'll see if
that doesn't matter let's keep on going
actually I was a gun man maybe the Z
will get rid of it may have a maybe will
turn out it's about the follies or
something I was not really spells oh my
gosh semicolon i would say good probably
semicolon I think she used a lot of fun
semicolon let's run out of words okay so
now we have to put in our own words what
do we do now well position sizes basis
okay yeah okay put in put in spaces
everywhere you can uh-huh
oh you have to tell where to go if you
don't just tell you where they go
you have to play next day oh I have the
answer sitting there too I was peeking
spice this will include rice after the
wheel that's pretty phrase after the way
hotter pilot sites good oh ok ok but we
got to be good leave it Ziggy is good
people time good good
I'm kind of sliced fully the whole way
so i guess the i need to let it would be
guardians nowhere nowhere um okay was
try know where somewhere anyway because
i really have two letters and then you
step up so much fun to say oh don't find
out with this on ok why the effect it
has on yo it's only a one thing it's
upset right know what it's going to be
online isn't it yes could be character
Mikey Mike yeah carriage return line
here's another puzzle I guess room that
would be a likely something sorted yes
okay
returns in line feedstock are I do
follow each other a little stuff in this
computer so that's another thing that we
can that's not thing if you have a line
feed it's gotta be followed by
appreciated by carried eternity got a
character it's got to be followed by
Lenny feet in this editor and that's par
for the course to you I mean a fair game
or whatever that the right that phrase
is you so that fit so that's it huh we
got a semicolon carriage return line
feed in there love the EKG change Oh
putting it okay let's see if we it was
possible to find out where carriage
return in mind whether you would oh ok
something like that line p okay okay now
let's see um okay Kathy this up I'll
give you a rest for a minute let me show
you I got a printout of the help of
another run to somebody else have a
program i think that they want to get
going on this bike no we won't nobody
it's okay so let's focus on this and and
i'll put this up on the f2 to look at in
similar england with which went on when
I was trying this just to give so we
have two two examples to look at okay
well let me just start off with this
easiest way to see the easiest way would
be to you in a bit okay now this is all
I'm not claiming that my program is
especially efficient but it's just
slightly different so they'll give us 22
things to look at and I was going I was
going on blindness let's try to fill T
to close up on hisses and good as you
can I'll be pasting up some other ones
as we go so see how we can do now let's
see so in some way my thing was was
somewhat a slightly different approach
but I i just said searching for the
probable word space the space and it
said five hits and so when I have a this
funny for all character that means that
I don't know anything about about it can
you get even closer no way okay so this
is fine print and so on the French are
using the other board and turning it
slightly to it well he's all set up for
that now so it could be okay um so
anyway I can read it to you it says
searching for probable word five hits
and it found five places then I tried
probable word space which on space said
no hits searching for power that one hit
then I said putting the word that
because they're all right that and that
caused a less than sign a 9 and a minus
sign to come in a hyphen conceivable but
the less than sign doesn't very good so
then it says backtracking to level 0
okay then I looked for the again and
started to insert the and I and I
inserted a as many laws as I could and I
started getting I start
getting garbage okay so that's that was
the initial thing and I wasn't getting
too far